[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans parlement
hebdo l'émission qui revient sur les
temps forts de l'actualité à l'assemblée
et au sénat et cette semaine avec
brigitte boucher notre invité d'aurélien
tâche et bonjour bonjour et c'est
brigitte qui vous présente
aurélien dachier bonjour vous êtes
député eds écologie démocratie et
solidarité du val d'oise très tôt engagé
au parti socialiste vous avez rejoint
emmanuel macron en 2010 est considéré
comme l'ailé gauche de la majorité vous
défendez une laïcité ouverte et
inclusive on y reviendra vous avez
contribué au projet de loi asile et
immigration avant de regretter cette loi
ainsi que la loi anti casseurs c'est ce
que vous dites aujourd'hui alors que
vous avez quitté il y a quelques mois le
groupe la république en marche avec
d'autres députés de la majorité pour
créer justement eds alors vous faites
partie des déçus du maquereau nisme si
manuel macron était à nouveau candidat
en 2022 est ce que vous pourriez revoter
pour lui pas sur la base de la politique
qui est conduite actuellement
donc ce sera au président de la
république s'il se décide à se
représenter ce qui pour l'instant
puisque personne ne sait pour le moment
de dire quel serait son projet mais je
dois avouer que je ne comprends pas au
regard de l'engagement qui a été le mien
à ses côtés en 2017 et pendant les trois
premières années du mandat
les choix qui sont faits actuellement le
nouveau premier ministre et son
gouvernement le discours de politique
générale qui a été fait en juillet m'ont
conduit à voter contre
pour la première fois où vous êtes dans
l'opposition à la majorité
aujourd'hui je me sens je ne me sens
plus du tout appartenir à la majorité et
votre voix si ce n'est pas emmanuel
macron aujourd'hui vous situez où moi
d'abord je veux moi je me suis toujours
revendiqué un homme de gauche
1 malgré le fait que ça fait grincer les
dents à certains y compris à gauche
parce que certains considèrent que quand
on est content a fait le choix des
manuels macro on ne peut pas se
revendiquer de gauche c'était pas vrai
il y avait des choses dans le corps dans
la campagne de 2007 sur la modernisation
de la démocratie sur l'égalité des
chances sur les libertés qui m'ont fait
soutenir ce candidat sans réserve
mais les trois premières années ont
quand même été ponctuée on va dire deux
choses parfois surprenantes et les choix
qui sont maintenant fais avec
une politique par exemple sur le plan de
l'immigration ou de de ski et conduit au
ministère de l'intérieur sur le vivre
ensemble et autres extrêmement
conservatrice sur le choix économiques
et sociales un plan de relance
entièrement tourné vers les entreprises
et qui oublie complètement les personnes
précaires qui va remettre sur la table
des réformes comme la réforme des
retraites ou de l'assurance chômage tous
ces choix là sont des choix qui pour moi
sont de droite donc je ne suis plus en
phase avec cette politique et on verra
en 2022 et j'ai d'abord 18 mois de
travail de parlementaires à faire aller
justement on va passer au titre de cette
émission la majorité donne du fil à
retordre à l'exécutif elle devait
entendre sa voix sur le retour des
néonicotinoïdes et impose un allongement
des délais dit vg contre l'avis du
gouvernement
cédric au devant la commission denquête
kovy du sénat le secrétaire d'état au
numérique reconnaît l'échec de
l'application stop qu'ovide et cherche
des alliés pour la relancer le projet de
loi sur le séparatisme a fait réagir
lors des questions au gouvernement à
l'assemblée à suivre dans cette émission
la passe d'armes entre le député la
france insoumise alexis corbière et le
ministre de l'intérieur gérald darmanin
et on commence par le palais bourbon où
les marcheurs sa franchise
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
fini les bons petits soldats la majorité
s'émancipe à l'assemblée sur le retour
des néonicotinoïdes le groupe la
république en marche a affiché un nombre
record de votes contre et d'abstention
les députés ont aussi approuvé
l'allongement des délais dit vg malgré
les réticences du gouvernement alzamora
gamme à 30 de votre contre 36
abstentions c'est un record jamais
autant de députés la république en
marche non refusé de suivre le
gouvernement le texte sur les
néonicotinoïdes a été adopté quand même
mais c'est le signe que désormais des
marcheurs n'hésitent plus à contrecarrer
l'exécutif pourtant pour cette marcheuse
de la première heure ce n'est pas une
fraude on est sur un sujet qui est
extrêmement sensibles sur lesquels il
n'y a pas de bonnes solutions il y a
toujours eu en tout cas dans nos débats
internes
l'expression de ces oppositions qu'elle
soit plus marquée dans l'hémicycle c'est
peut-être le cas mais c'est peut-être
juste la séquence et le fait qu'on ait
ces grosses et ces textes là qu'ils se
regroupent qui fait qu'on voit davantage
mais moi je n'ai jamais vu de godillots
parmi les députés de la république en
marche autre exemple où le groupe la
république en marche donne des signes
d'émancipation l'allongement du délai
légal pour liv et j'ai même si là ce
n'est pas un projet de l'exécutif mais
une proposition d'anciens marcheurs
le gouvernement n'en voulait pas je ne
peux en conscience considéré que nous
disposions de tous les éléments pour
prendre une telle décision aujourd'hui
dans l'hémicycle des députés macro nist
ont rejeté en bloc les arguments du
ministre pas question d'attendre l'avis
du comité consultatif national d'éthique
saisie par le gouvernement
aujourd'hui lives et jenny pas d'une
question d'éthique
c'est une question de droits des femmes
et il s'agit bien donc de faire en sorte
que ce droit ne soit plus un droit
totémique mais un droit réel
la majorité a donc largement voté pour
autoriser les ivg jusqu'à la 14e semaine
de grossesse qui contre l'avis du
gouvernement
aurélien attaché cette proposition de
loi pour allonger les délais de libé est
une proposition du groupe ds de votre
groupe est ce que vous avez
objectivement chercher à déstabiliser la
majorité
mais non on a simplement cherché à lui
rappeler ses fondamentaux
tous ces sujets là ce qu'ils ont été qui
aurait dû être étudiée hier dans dans
l'année
parlementaires du groupe edf c'est comme
ça qu'il est convenu d'appeler les
journées où les groupes d'opposition ou
minoritaires comme nous peuvent déposer
des propositions de loi sont des sujets
qui avait été travaillé par beaucoup
d'entre nous quand nous étions en groupe
en marge et dont nous savions qu'une
majorité de collègues étaient favorables
à ces sujets là simplement ce groupe
parlementaire n'a jamais su se faire
respecter
n'a jamais su affirmer son identité
politique et a laissé le gouvernement à
chaque fois l'empêcher d'aller au bout
des propositions qui leur est offert le
même moi je sais que sa pression du
groupe l'art et bien sûr moi je sais que
ça a frustré énormément de collègues et
hier ils ont pris leurs responsabilités
je les salue ils ont été courageux
contre l'avis du gouvernement par
exemple sur cette fois sur l'île et ils
ont dit non ça fait partie des
fondamentaux du progressisme dans
lesquels on avait cru en 2017 et donc on
va jouer notre rôle de parlementaire et
elle m'a conseillé progressisme
je ne peux que malheureusement faire ce
constat
je ne peux que faire ce constat quand je
lis dans les déclarations de presque le
président de république et le premier
ministre considère que ce sujet et clive
qu'il faudrait reprendre des années pour
discuter de ça ce sont les mêmes
arguments que ceux qui sont opposés aux
avancées sur la bioéthique ou sur les
questions de société d'une manière
générale donc c'était un réflexe
conservateur et en plus excuser moi je
sais pas si ses propos sont vraies mais
on dit que il aurait dit où le premier
ministre que c'était quelque chose qui
ne devraient pas être débattus dans une
antichambre une obscure commission
bonjour quand même
ils disent aussi au niveau du groupe lrm
que c'est du populisme électoral qu'est
ce que vous leur répondez à ceux là sur
cette mesure sur cette passion des
belles sur un certain nombre de
négociations on est un
on était une majorité qui justement
normalement en finlande puis comment
j'avais été fondée sur l'idée qu'on
allait être moderne ouvert faire à l'est
de la france a fait râler la france va
vers l'avant vers l'avenir et donc tous
ces sujets sont des sujets qui sont au
coeur des attentes des citoyens
les gens aujourd'hui veulent que sur la
souffrance animale on avance et qu'on
arrête de traiter les animaux de manière
cruelle
les gens veulent que les droits des
femmes soient finalement renforcé que le
les pères puissent prendre leurs congés
comme les mères tout ça c'est des
avancées sociétales progressiste sinon
je ne comprends pas le défilé un plus
grand débat peut-être sur libé j'ai dans
la société où tu joues toujours sur
l'allongement des délais c'est toujours
quand on est passé du 17 12
douze à quatre ça fait toujours débat
quand même une majorité de français qui
sont favorables ça et puis on a été élu
sur l'idée que justement on allait faire
reculer les conservatismes donc c'est
aujourd'hui l'attitude du gouvernement
qui est incompréhensible par rapport à
l'électorat 2017 on a bien compris que
l'électorat 2017 n'intéressait plus le
président la république et le
gouvernement qu'il veut en chercher un
autre pan 2022 bon et bien les députés
eux sont restés fidèles à ce qu'ils ont
et à ce qu'ils sont et à ce pour quoi
ils ont été vus en 2000 sur le fond sur
les vg il ya quand même vraiment débat
par exemple et bien israël nisand dit
qu'ils effectuent une ivg à 14 semaines
de grossesse n'a rien d'anodin c'est un
acte lourd potentiellement dangereux
qu'est ce que vous lui répondez parce
que lui ai dit c'est pas du tout la même
chose d'un point de vue médical
écoutez peut-être certains spécialistes
qui disent à d'autres disent tout à fait
autre chose moi j'ai vu par exemple le
syndicat des jeunes médecins ou d'autres
organisations qui sont très largement
favorables qui disent qu on peut
pratiquer une ivg dans de bonnes
conditions
à quatorze semaines que ça se fait
d'ailleurs dans un certain nombre de
pays
pourquoi nous avons proposé cette fois
parce qu'aujourd'hui les femmes qui
veulent pratiquer une ivg souvent les
rendez-vous sont tellement longs ce
droit n'est tellement pas être si
problème les rendez-vous sont tellement
loin oui c'est ça qu'il faut pas d'abord
oui mais il arrive aussi parfois que
certaines femmes voient la situation à
un moment où elles vont être obligés de
le faire après 12 semaines entre 12 et
14 semaines
et qu'est-ce qui se passe pour celles
qui en ont les moyen terme 3000 à 5000
femmes c'est ça pour celles qui en ont
les moyens elles partent le faire
ailleurs en europe
et pour celles qui n'ont pas les moyens
et bien elles ne peuvent pas pratiquer
les ivg c'est une question d'égalité
sociale moi je suis très attaché à la
question de la lutte contre les
inégalités donc je suis favorable à
cette mesure
et vous pensez que cette proposition de
loi ira au bout on sait que les
socialistes veulent la porter au sénat
et vous pensez qu'elle sera remise aussi
à l'ordre du jour avant 2022 on voit que
c'est vrai difficile
c'est un combat qu'il va falloir mener
mais on va maintenir une pression je
salue d'ailleurs les collègues
socialistes qui effectivement ont été
exemplaires hier dans les débats nous
ont soutenus je sais que les sénateurs
et notamment certains de sénatrice mme
tellement leur signale un père de la
gontrie d'autres sont très en pointe sur
cette question donc on compte sur elle
pour faire avancer les choses ici alors
faire inscrire ce texte dans leur propre
niche dans la niche socialiste vous
allez donc collaboré avec le groupe
socialiste oui bah écoutez moi à titre
personnel je trouve c'est une bonne
chose
moi je suis plutôt je trouve que c'est
bien qu'on puisse travailler ensemble et
puis plus sérieusement on avait toujours
dit nous cologie démocratie solidarité
que notre but est de trouver des
majorités de projets sur les sujets qui
nous semblait important avec les
socialistes avec en marge avec tous ceux
qui veulent bien travailler sur les
sujets qui nous semble important en
matière d'écologie de démocratie de
solidarité
vous avez dit tout à l'heure que
emmanuel macron voyait son groupe
parlementaire finalement tel qu'il est
tel qu'il était en 2017
vous pensez qu'aujourd'hui manuel da
cruz n'a plus forcément de majorité à
l'assemblée nationale plus compliqué que
ça mais ce qui est vrai et d'ailleurs
personne ne s'en rappelle mais dans le
dans le dans le contrat qu'on avait
signé puisqu'on avait signé espèces
d'engagement six engagements envers à
emmanuel macron et la nation quand on
devient les députés de la pluie dimanche
il avait l'idée justement qu'on cherche
des majorités de projets sur les sujets
qu'on refuse ces catégories fermé
majorité opposition ferme des coalitions
fils exactement de faire progresser
cette culture de la coalition en
français au parlement j'ai le sentiment
que ça a été bien oubliée par le
gouvernement ça depuis 2010 est nous on
est quelques uns s'en rappeler juste un
mot sur l'attitude de christophe
castaner le nouveau président du groupe
de la république en marche il a voté
avec vous alors qu'est ce que ça veut
dire ça veut dire qu'il est vraiment
d'accord avec vous qui tient pas ses
troupes
qu'est ce que ça veut dire aller poser
la question à lui est en tout cas il a
pris ses responsabilités il a voté donc
je peux que saluer son acte jeu quand
même le silence
j'ai quand même le sentiment pour avoir
échangé avec un certain nombre de
collègues de la majorité que de toute
façon s'il ne l'avait pas fait ça aurait
été compliqué pour le président de
groupe qu'il a il avait une vraiment
beaucoup de députés qui de toute façon
aller le faire donc il a appris sa
responsabilité en disant je constate
jacques tu que mais mes troupes vont
voter pourrait donc je les suis je ne
vais pas me désolidariser d'elle non
mais voilà il dessus mais ne le dirigent
pas coûté en tout cas on a bien le
sentiment que de toute façon il était
décidé à voter un voile à aller au
niveau si cette émission avec l'audition
de cédric au devant la commission
denquête qu'ovide au sénat
[Musique]
le secrétaire d'état à la transition
numérique a été malmené par les
sénateurs lors de son audition au coeur
des discussions l'échec de l'application
stop covin celle ci dessous l'audition a
commencé par une question du président
de la commission denquête alain milon
qui visiblement était d'humeur taquine
est ce que votre monde connecté a
ressenti une augmentation de votre
rythme cardiaque lorsque le premier
ministre a annoncé qu'il n'avait pas
enregistré
l'application qu'ovide comme le premier
ministre la plupart des français n'ont
pas téléchargé l'application stop
qu'ovide pendant près de deux heures les
sénateurs ont cherché à comprendre les
raisons de cet échec
comment vous explique r le relatif
heures quand je sais gentil d'entendre
et ifs échec du dispositif pourquoi 65
millions de français ne veulent pas
télécharger et utiliser cet outil 3 ça
ne marche pas pourquoi on a loupé en
fait le coche si cédric hauck reconnaît
que l'outil n'a attiré que 2,2 millions
de français le secrétaire d'état en
charge de la transition numérique estime
que c'est parce que l'application est
sorti au mauvais moment juste après le
déconfinement mais pas seulement le vrai
sujet c'est que les français ne
comprennent pas l'intérêt qu'ils ont
personnel à télécharger stop colline une
réponse qui a laissé perplexe plusieurs
sénateurs
on a l'impression qu'ils aient une vraie
défiance du gouvernement vis-à-vis des
français tant que vous avez des
relations comme ça c'est le médecin qui
parle c'est peux pas marcher quoique
dans toute entreprise qui lance contre
guillemets un produit quand elle lancé
ça ne marche pas ils se disent pas c'est
la faute du client 10 c'est ma faute
donc à un moment donné il va falloir que
vous regardiez votre responsabilité pour
que la confiance revienne redonner
confiance aux français pour relancer
l'application c'est désormais l'objectif
affiché par cédric au qui compte sur les
professionnels de santé mais aussi les
acteurs économiques pour en faire la
promotion
si nous voulons relancer l'application
nous avons besoin de trouver des relais
et des alliés nous avons besoin que si
les professions médicales estiment que
c'est utile alors elles doivent le dire
si les responsables de cafés hôtels
restaurants estime que c'est petit
quelque chose qui aidera ne pas refermer
les établissements recevant du public
alors il faut qu'il nous aide parce que
les gens téléchargent ou active stop
qu'ovide faire marcher l'application
avant que cela ne devienne aussi un
fiasco financier car depuis le mois de
juin
l'application coûterait près de 100000
euros à l'état selon cédric au aurélien
tâche et qu'est ce qui explique pour
vous et bien l'échec de l'application
stop covin mme elhady cedrico il a dit
que les français n'en ne comprenait pas
l'intérêt je vous faire une confidence
moi non plus visiblement jean castex non
plus donc elle est chargée l'application
de toute façon moi je suis contre aussi
pour des raisons de principe c'est à
dire que on a une défense des libertés
individuelles qui questionnait par ce
genre d'application oui j'ai prononcé
mais moi je ne comprends pas l'usagé
qu'on veut que l'on veut faire de cette
application tracer les français ne me
semble pas la bonne manière de lutter
contre le coc vide les seuls crédits
besoin d'un outil de traçage on voit
combien c'est compliqué aujourd'hui de
remonter les chaînes de comprendre où se
situent les clusters qui sont plutôt sur
la formation de ces clusters regarder
j'étais en train de regarder ce matin ce
qui se passait en allemagne en allemagne
pendant qu'on est en train de s'écharper
en france sur le masque sur la clau la
chloroquine sur stop qu'ovide eux ils se
sont rendus compte qu en aérant les
pièces ont tué les clusters donc toutes
les 20 minutes ont par exemple les
écoles on ouvre les fenêtres pour que ce
soit finalement aéré et ça tue le coc
vide c'est un petit peu contraignant
donc les ingénieurs allemands se sont
mis à travailler sur des solutions de
purificateurs d'air et par exemple qu'on
arrive à éliminer des clusters comme ça
toujours fasciné par la manière dont en
france on a habité contre une pandémie
mondiale en ouvrant les fenêtres et
baies écoutez il faut croire que les
allemands s'engagent dans cette voie
alors évidemment ils ne se sont pas
limités à cette méthode internationale
mais effectivement mais regardez il ya
des choses sur le plan sioniste un
travail sur la rh je veux dire c'est que
sur le plan technique à d'autres voient
qu'on pourrait privilégier
mettons les moyens de l'état cédric au
jeu des vues moi cette audition n'est
pas capable de répondre sur le coût de
cette application devant les sénateurs
et la représentation nationale de saint
nazaire euros par mois voilà la peur
d'être très sûr de lui donc moi je
trouve que par exemple on aurait pu
mettre cet argent pour effectivement
travailler sur des perruques des
purificateurs d'air dans les pièces
comme le font les allemands ou d'autres
solutions et qui sont quand même sur le
plan des libertés beaucoup moins
discutable donc
des libertés quand on à facebook on a un
stade g on a d'autres réseaux sociaux on
n'est pas déjà très très susceptibles
d'être d'être repéré c'est vrai il ya
des débats à voir sur cette question
j'étais favorable par exemple à ce qu'on
organise une convention citoyenne sur
ces questions je souhaiterais que les
données personnelles fasse l'objet d'un
grand débat en france qu' on puisse être
propriétaires de ces données que les
gars femmes arrêtent de les piller mais
là il ya une différence c'est que c'est
le gouvernement qui peut nous tracer
facebook c'est moi qui choisis qui
finalement dans mes amis peut me suivre
et je sais que facebook prend un peu
mais 2d mais bon je le faire conscience
de cause que le gouvernement sache tous
mes faits et gestes et qui puisse me
tracer je trouve que c'est un problème
pour les libertés et que ça ne peut pas
être réglé comme ça avec une application
un peu à la va-vite dont on ne sait même
pas l'efficacité dont on ne sait même
pas le coût donc non c'est une mauvaise
solution
j'ai entendu le secrétaire d'état a
parlé de relancer ce top quoi bein moi
je lui conseille plutôt d'y renoncer
définitivement à ce que vous voyez
qu'aujourd'hui tous les restaurants vont
noter les coordonnées de leurs clients à
ce que vous vous dites pas que ce top
cow vite c'est quand même plus
protecteur de données parce que là on va
mettre toutes nos coordonnées sur des
pages auxquelles tout le monde va avoir
accès au si pas très à l'aise avec cette
mesure
je trouve un peu bizarre quand je vais
dans un restaurant en ce moment en cours
me demande mon téléphone mon nom que le
préfet de police récupère tous ah bon je
trouve que tout ça est quand même un peu
étrange que on est le seul pays à
pratiquer de cette manière il y aurait
certainement d'autres voies explorées
j'en ai vu quelques unes parce que c'est
l actualité du jour sur ce qui se passe
en allemagne qu'on pourrait utiliser
pour lutter contre cette pandémie vous
savez moi je suis assez inquiet au delà
du virus qui reparaît ne faut pas
négliger ça il faut évidemment respecter
les gestes barrière il faut évidemment
porter les masques
je suis quand même assez inquiets de la
gestion de crise et de l'allant que la
situation très anxiogène qui finalement
est celle qu'on connaît en france
aujourd'hui avec une communication qui
paraît erratique tous les deux jours on
a un teasing du gouvernement sur il va y
avoir des nouvelles mesures restrictives
on sait pas bien quoi ça angoisse les
gens la dernière fois c'était un
dimanche soir à 22h30 c'est quand même
un peu étonnant et moi je suis inquiète
des pathologies que ça va développer sur
sur la santé des français les médecins
me disent vous savez tout cette anxiété
là on voit des gens qui sont vraiment
maintenant dans une souffrance et ça on
ne mesure pas encore le coup sur le plan
sanitaire et social si on en est là
aujourd'hui c'est à cause d'une
désorganisation de l'hôpital c'est parce
que l'état n'a pas suffisamment mis les
moyens
je pense qu'il y à ce sujet là c'est
très clair et d'ailleurs le président de
la république l'a reconnu lui-même en
disant on n'a pas été assez vite on
m'avait pas mis assez de moyens bon très
bien donc maintenant il va peut-être
falloir accélérer
un plan de 100 milliards d'euros bon les
100 milliards d'euros c'est toujours
pareil c'est les entreprises des
entreprises des entreprises les services
publics la loi de finances de la
sécurité sociale le ségur de la santé
pour améliorer justement à la fois les
revalorisations de salaires et aussi
l'organisation technique de l'hôpital
mais les salaires c'est très bien c'est
une question de justice sociale pas moi
qui vais vous dire que je suis contre ça
mais en revanche ça ne règle pas la
question des effectifs et des moyens de
l'hôpital et on va le faire
immédiatement et c'est ce qu'on disait
long terme
il avait été fait sur le numerus clausus
et serra qui avait été quand même
analyse est pas encore mais je constate
simplement que quand c'est les
entreprises on trouve 100 milliards
d'euros tout de suite vous pensez qu
aura pas de reconfirmer là aujourd'hui
on voit que l'étau se resserre de plus
en plus de nouvelles villes maintenant
son temps en zone d' alerte maximale
c'est difficile à dire aujourd'hui on ne
peut pas complètement l'éviter je pense
à ce stade
et puis de toute façon il faut que la
santé prime donc s'il fallait le faire
il faudra le faire mais les français
seraient prêts à l'accepter aujourd'hui
si ce sera difficile vous savez j'ai dit
il ya d'autres d'autres conséquences
qu'on ne mesure pas encore aujourd'hui
sur le plan social sur le plan sanitaire
de ce que l de ce qu'un produit le
confinement de ce que produit finalement
le climat d'anxiété dans le pays donc ce
sera très difficile moi je pense qu'il
faut vraiment maintenant mettre le
paquet sur l'hôpital qu'il faut
travailler sur des solutions techniques
type aération et autres qui peuvent
éviter de former des clusters qu'il faut
trouver d'autres manières de vivre avec
le virus pour reprendre l'expression
d'un certain nombre de membres du
gouvernement à les orienter h et on
termine avec le plus de la semaine
[Musique]
le projet de loi contre le séparatisme
sera présenté le 9 décembre en conseil
des ministres mais il fait déjà débat à
l'assemblée ce mardi lors des questions
au gouvernement
alexis corbière a accusé le gouvernement
de stigmatiser les musulmans
écoutez le député la france insoumise et
la réponse que lui a faits du ministre
de l'intérieur
nous désapprouvons enfin votre ambition
de se mêler de l'organisation d'un culte
voilà comment renforcer la laïcité et
les principes républicains
selon le nouveau nom de votre projet de
loi mais il nous semble évident que vous
voulez fabriquer un agenda médiatique où
durant des mois vous répéter des mots
qu'ensuite vous peinez à définir tel le
séparatiste puisque vous l'avez
abandonné dans le titre de votre projet
futur projet de loi
ainsi vous contourner les problèmes
sociaux et sanitaires qui déchire notre
pays en saturant l'opinion d'une
question obsessionnelle l'islam l'islam
l'islam
je ne m'excuse pas car si comme le vôtre
a dénoncé pendant longtemps le podium du
peuple en soit désormais lié avec un
islam au gauchisme qui détruit la
république
voilà la réalité monsieur corbières ce
que nous faisons ce n'est pas simplement
manifestement de gêner quelques
islamistes radicaux mais quand j'entends
vos propos et celle du président
mélenchon je sens qu'on gêne aussi
beaucoup de votre corps électoral
aurélien tâche est ce que la france
insoumise et complaisante avec l'islam
j'suis pas monde la france a soumis donc
moi je n'ai pas à me prononcer là-dessus
ce que je vois en tout cas c'est radical
il faut être absolument intransigeant
avec l'islam radical mais c'est un sujet
sérieux et quand je vois la manière dont
gérald darmanin répond manière
politicienne vraiment on voit que l'on
n'entre pas dans le fond on fait des dd
de la rhétorique sur l'opium du peuple
parce que c'était une phrase de marx ou
autre je mets et qu'on essaie de
disqualifier la gauche pour parler de
ces sujets là je trouve que c'est
vraiment en dessous de 2 du débat et que
ce n'est pas du tout comme ça qu'on va
régler ce genre de ceux de problèmes ces
problèmes sont très graves il ils ont
coûté la vie à de nombreux français il
mine dans certains quartiers
effectivement la vie sociale et la
cohésion de la nation
mais pour être efficace là dessus il
faut faire un peu moins de communication
mettre beaucoup plus de moyens est
véritablement à les traiter les
problèmes à la racine
cette loi-là qui était d'abord une loi
sur le séparatisme bon j'arrête non
ils ont changé de nom parce qu'ils
n'arrivent pas à bien définir le concept
et le nom déjà ça commence bien il
aurait peut-être fallu travailler un
petit peu plus avant de faire un projet
on voit bien qu'ils savent pas ce qu'ils
vont mettre dedans donc à des mesures de
communication qui sont un peu agités
comme ça lors d'un grand discours oui il
n macron on a le sentiment que du coup
ça va être une loi pour régir le culte
de l'islam en france
voilà ce qui va rester dans cette loi
donc effectivement c'est une loi sur
l'islam dans ce sens par alexis corbière
a raison est ce que c'est vraiment à
l'état de venir organiser le culte comme
ça d'organiser une espèce de l'ambiance
un peu de chasse aux sorcières sur
chaque association musulmane en france
pour voir si oui ou non elle est plus ou
moins que ça a été fait avec chaque
religion il ya eu la loi de 1905 avait
eu le concordat aussi avec les juges
est-ce qu'il faut pas organiser l'islam
de france aujourd'hui
moi je ne crois pas le concordat c'est
une logique qui a été une logique il ya
deux siècles pour pour le pour le
judaïsme mais qui n'est pas applicable à
l'islam l'islam n'a pas de 2,2 clergé
l'islam mais le l'état français n'est
plus dans cette logique là nous avons la
loi de 1905 qui sépare l'état et la
religion
il y a à lutter contre l'islamisme
radical ça c'est très clair pour ça vous
voyez dans le projet de loi pas
tellement et 6 mois vous savez ce que je
pense je pense que la meilleure loi pour
lutter contre l'islam l'islamisme
radical c'est la loi de finances 1
c'est dans la loi de finances qu'on
pourrait financer par exemple des
logements sociaux ailleurs que dans les
quartiers où ils sont concentrés et
qu'ils poursuivent à des logiques de
ghettoïsation c'est dans la loi de
finances comparait financer une offre
alternative d'éducation populaire pour
que les jeunes puissent se tourner quand
ils ont des questions sur leur religion
sur le l'égalité entre les femmes et les
hommes vers les associations qui leur
apportera des réponses autre que celle
des islamistes
tout ça c'est des moyens les services
publics dans ces quartiers aussi et puis
bien sûr pour la sécurité sur la police
contre le terrorisme là aussi il faut
rajouter des moyens tout le reste n'est
qu'agitation politique et corbières a
raison sur une chose c'est que ils
veulent installer un agenda médiatique
pendant 12 mois pour finalement plutôt
qu'on parle des problèmes de précarité
plutôt qu'on parle des problèmes de
pauvreté 1 millions de pauvres en plus
en france c'est là dessus qu'il faudrait
une grande noir et bien qu'on parle
d'islam
c'est une manière mathis s'adresse à la
droite en est évidemment on s'adapte
c'est pas moi qui le dit c'est marine le
pen et stéphane ravier qui disent
qu'elle s'étonne de temps de convergence
de vue avec gérald darmanin qui n'ont
jamais vu un président avec autant
d'inscriptions sur ces sujets que
stéphane ravier le sénateur qui est qui
siège ici dit 'oui' et marlène schiappa
je voudrais la féliciter personnellement
bon ben voila je crois que tout est dit
vous
fait le reproche notamment chez vos
anciens alliés d'être complaisant avec
l'islam notamment lorsque vous avez
défendu récemment cette représentante de
l'unef vous allez auditionné à
l'assemblée
est ce que pour vous elle n'affichait
pas un islam politique d'abord je ne
peux pas le savoir
je ne suis pas dans sa tête il doit il
faudrait lui poser la question à l donc
moi je ne suis pas d'accord sur le fait
que dès qu'une femme en france portent
un voile ce serait pour afficher un
islam politique certaine sauf qu'à la
fin elle porte aussi des revendications
politiques
oui mais qui sont les revendications de
l'unef time je suis un ancien de l'unef
s'est pas infâmant d'être à l'unef il ne
va pas changer tous les droits des
étudiants c'est tout pas un message
politique en choisissant une femme
voilée comme représentante s'est pas
l'unef qui a changé c'est la jeunesse
française qui ait changé il ya
aujourd'hui plus de jeunes qui sont de
culture musulmane en france c'est tout
donc certains prennent des
responsabilités
peut-être que cette jeune femme porte le
voile pour un islam politique peut-être
qu'elles le pensent juste pour des
raisons religieuses peut-être qu'elle ne
porte par habitude ça lui appartient
il faut lutter contre l'islamisme
radical il ne faut pas confondre ça avec
l'islam le port du voile peut être il
peut y avoir autant de raisons de porter
le voile qu est ce qu il ya de femmes en
france
voilà donc elle fait un choix on
respecte son choix et puis si un jour on
voit qu'elle a des revendications
politiques ou dangereuses
eh bien on la condamnera pour ça mais en
attendant on la respecte parce que
pascal a fait ce choix il ya une annonce
du président la république sur la
neutralité des salariés neutralité
religieuse pour les entreprises
publiques et délégataire de service
public
est ce que vous craignez une
stigmatisation là aussi moi je crains qu
effectivement on est une ambiance dans
le pays qui n'est quand même pas bonne
vous savez je vais vous donner un
chiffre
il ya une ong qui s'appelle destin
commun qui fait un très bon travail sur
l'une ensemble qui a prouvé que 62% des
français étaient inquiets du climat
d'hostilité à l'égard des musulmans et
même dans l'électorat de la droite
traditionnelle un peu dur les gens se
disent oui c'est vrai que quand même les
musulmans en france là y'a quand même un
climat d'hostilité un peu généralisés
donc moi je suis très attaché à la
laïcité
l'état doit être neutre les entreprises
qui relèvent de l'état aussi
c'est très bien mais est-ce qu'on avait
besoin de faire une grande loi
uniquement sur l'islam d'avoir toute
cette agitation par gérald darmanin et
marlène schiappa toutes les semaines je
crois même qu emmanuel macron son est
agacé il ya peu de temps
je pense qu'il ya d'autres manières de
faire il faut le faire de manière
apaisée
merci aurélien tâche et mercy était mme
tran huy et on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau parlement et
d'eau
[Musique]